our farts funny do you think farts are
funny
I yeah yeah I do yeah why I don't know
why I just think they're funny no no no
they're not funny do you think arts are
funny you really noisy you hunt the
really noisy ones are funny
no farts they are yeah yes No so you've
never laughed it apart oh yeah of course
yeah so then sometimes they're funny
yeah
[Music]
yeah what no what makes parts funny
[Music]
depends
have you ever left it apart I'm sure I
have I'm British so we find that kind of
stuff funny like that yeah that's pretty
good
thanks do you think farts are funny
clearly definitively
I mean I don't know when they're not
funny they might be inappropriate but it
doesn't mean it's not funny
those are two different those two
difference do you think farts are funny
no farts aren't funny I'm done horse
around
Larry's sometimes
[Music]
no I think they're funny yet not really
sometimes
[Music]
excuse me was that funny
[Music]
so what do you think our parts funny
[Music]